c'est bienvenu ou fait saclay nous
sommes sur le bord de la rivière
saint-maurice à 3 reagan certains
connaissent ces lieux sur le nom de
fontaine du diable je m'appelle l'usp et
oui je suis de wemotaci
je suis natif avec marc et une coco que
veut des grands mâles je vais vous
guider en ce lieu que nous les
attikameks appelons le feu sacré je vous
fait vivre ce moment pour qu'il vous
inspire
vous aussi
et
[Musique]
le lieu a été gardé secret pas dans
longtemps pour toi que les clergés où le
gouvernement des blancs n'utilise
ensemble on va explorer la nature qui
nous entoure
[Musique]
comme il ya beaucoup d'énergie au feu
sacré j'ai eu l'inspiration de célébrer
une cérémonie de la pleine lune on va
commencer par se vérifier avec de la
sauce
on vient pour remercier nos ancêtres
pour qu'il continue de veiller sur nous
et surtout pour être plus forts de nos
vies le feu sacré m'a aidé a traversé
bien des épreuves familiales seco comme
carmen qui m'a initié à ce rituel qui
s'est déroulé entre femmes un seul homme
peut y participer sur le gardien de feu
aujourd'hui c'est le guide spirituel
marcel petits gris qui va nous faire
s'étonnant l'homme entretient le feu et
la femme un porteuse d'eau regarde les
taps quincy be c'est le nom que nous
donnons à la liesse et maïs
tapscott libye est au coeur de notre
territoire
le taximan elle était ce important pour
nous l'eau aussi importantes que les
femmes en bois tirant la cérémonie il en
donne la thermale les femmes portent
l'eau comme elle porte les bébés l'eau
c'est la vie c'est sacré le grand esprit
que je suis venu prix ne va pas me
donner ce que je veux mais plutôt ce qui
est bon pour moi la première fois que je
suis venu ici j'étais vraiment
bouleversée quand mon mari et moi il y
avait une mauvaise énergie
alors j'ai écrit une lettre aux grands
esprits pour retrouver man harmonie
familiale et pour lui transmettre je les
brûle et dans le feu sacré avec du
tabloïd cède autour de nous le grand
esprit est toujours présent dans chacune
des armes des gardes ou
voici une histoire que mon père me
racontait c'est l'histoire du loup dans
chaque personne il y à une bataille
entre le bon et le méchant loup le bon
goût est alimentée par la bienveillance
l'humilité de la compassion le méchant
loup est alimentée par la colère légaux
et leur arrogance camille ans est une
réponse j'ai mal j'ai pris conscience du
méchant loup qui est en moi je n'ai pas
reçu la réponse que j'attendais mais
plutôt ce que je devais faire alors j'ai
quitté mon mari nous avons le pouvoir de
déterminer lequel des deux va gagner moi
je suis venu au feu sacré pour trouver
la force et le courage de combattre le
mauvais goût et même si ça a été très
difficile
le feu sacré m'a permis de me libérer je
me suis sentie complice et écouter
[Musique]
c'est un moment privilégié qui nous
partageons ici on peut plier et chanter
cal maine et moi j'entends à l'honneur
de l'eau qui brille devant à la fin de
chaque cérémonie en partage de la
nourriture comme de la banique et des
petits flux ces moments de partage
autour de feu sacré me rapproche de moi
même et des autres nouveaux skis gemalto
machi
[Musique]
mais
[Rires]
voilà est choqué